Let's break through the word count example by writing
a mapper and reducer in Python. Recall that the mapper
will take in a document. In this case, a collection
of words that appear in Alice in Wonderland, and will
return various intermediate key value pairs. In this case, each
word in the value one. These key value pairs will
then be shuffled to ensure that every key value pair
with the same key ends up on the same reducer.
And each reducer will perform some operation
on all of the values corresponding to a
particular key. In order to produce one
final key value pair. In this particular case,
we're counting up how many times each
word occurred. So for Alice, Wonderland, Caterpillar, and
Of, the final key value pair is Alice
one, Wonderland one, Caterpillar one and Of, one.
Whereas two appeared twice, so the final key value pair there is Was two.